ponts. On cède des locaux à des
artistes. Voici mon reportage.
- Dans le centre-ville
de Montréal, ce ne sont pas
les locaux commerciaux vacants
qui manquent ni les bonnes
idées. Le projet Créer des ponts
par Art Souterrain, offre
ces locaux vacants durant trois
mois à des artistes émergents.
FRÉDÉRIC LOURY, fondateur et
directeur général Art Souterrain
- Un projet comme celui-là
a un effet. D'un côté ça va
aider le milieu immobilier
parce qu'on montre les commerces
vacants sous les meilleures
auspices. Et de l'autre côté,
ces jeunes artistes-là, pour
eux, c'est une aubaine
de pouvoir avoir un lieu
de création et de vendre sans
intermédiaires leurs oeuvres
d'art à de nouveaux
collectionneurs.
- L'initiative, financée par
les propriétaires fonciers et
la ville de Montréal, permet
aux artistes de voir plus grand.
MORGAN LEGARÉ,
artiste en arts visuels
- Je travaille l'installation,
donc normalement, j'ai besoin
d'assez d'espace, assez
d'hauteur de plafond juste pour
laisser la pièce respirer puis
m'aider à la visualiser.
Donc c'est vraiment formidable
d'avoir accès à un espace
comme ça.
- L'idée derrière le projet est
aussi de sortir l'art des musées
et des galeries et d'aller
à la rencontre des gens.
- On sort des musées, on sort
des fondations on va vraiment
partout ailleurs, ça permet
aussi de faire rencontre entre
artiste et public un peu plus,
je dirais, novice.
- Le public pourra en effet
visiter ces résidences
d'artistes et échanger avec eux.
THIERRY DU BOIS, photographe
- C'est vraiment une motivation
puis le contact avec le public,
c'est vraiment intéressant aussi
parce qu'on a un point d'entrée
avec eux pour pouvoir
communiquer puis ça,
c'est vraiment essentiel, on se
sent pas tout seuls.
Moi, j'ai besoin de prendre
des avis des gens, de voir
comment ils réagissent."
- Les artistes sont jumelés par
équipe de 2 par local, ce qui
permettra de créer des ponts
entre les artistes aussi.
TINA MARAIS STRUTHERS, artiste
en arts textiles et visuels
- Je suis jumelée avec Isabelle
Parson qui est une autre artiste
photographe et on trouve
une conversation assez
intéressante entre
nos matières différentes.
- Une bouffée d'air frais après
une année de pandémie qui
a limité les occasions de
diffusion et d'échange pour
les artistes.
ISABELLE PARSON,
artiste en arts visuels
- Pendant la COVID, je pense
que les artistes ont beaucoup
produit, on était à la maison,
on avait le temps. Puis d'avoir
l'opportunité de sortir,
de montrer ces choses-là,
ça fait du bien.
- Les organisateurs espèrent que
l'expérience Créer des ponts
inspirera d'autres organismes
ailleurs au pays.
- Absolument, en fait ce projet-
là doit servir d'exemple. Et si
on peut faire en sorte que ça
puisse encourager d'autres
organisations à suivre le pas,
mais aussi même à Art souterrain
Aussià développer d'autres
alliances, je pense que ça peut
servir toute la communauté
des arts.
- Créer des ponts est à
découvrir jusqu'au 15 octobre.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Charti